foreign
medicine I've encountered a wide number
of medical diagnoses you see it turns
out that there are more than 60 000
different medical diagnoses that you can
list on a patient's chart you can
actually be diagnosed with a burn injury
when your water skis catch on fire
there are also codes if you need surgery
after being bitten by a pig
hit by a spacecraft
stabbed while crocheting or my favorite
due to extreme problems with your
in-laws
but the best of all has got to be the
code for getting sucked into a jet
engine
and the reason that I like this one is
because this is not the code for the
first time this happens but for the
subsequent encounter
so there must be people on this Earth
that have been sucked into a jet engine
twice
but I think you know kidding aside we
have to recognize that every last one of
us in this room is most likely to die of
only one of two diagnoses and these of
course are either cancer
or cardiovascular disease
this speaks to the incredible Public
Health importance of these two diseases
and the urgent unmet medical need to
develop new therapies directed against
them
a lot of people are not surprised that
these two diseases claim so many lives
after all they are very different
biologically they have different risk
factors and they affect very different
patient populations
but for the next 15 minutes or so I
would like to propose a different
hypothesis that perhaps they actually
have quite a lot in common
and even more importantly I would like
to suggest that if we think about them
this way we might be able to develop new
therapies that could treat both diseases
at the same time
so before I tell you why I believe this
hypothesis let me lay out the counter
arguments against it
I think many people would say that the
old man who smokes cigarettes his whole
life and has a heart attack shares very
little in common with the young person
who develops colon cancer out of the
blue
but we now know that the risk factors
for these diseases have significant
overlap and the things that cause one
disease can also put you at risk for the
other
well that may be true but we know that
genetically these diseases couldn't be
more different I'm sure many of you have
heard about these cancer genes that can
be mutated in families that could put
both mother and daughter at risk for
breast cancer
we know that those genes have nothing to
do with heart attack
and that's true also but I would point
out that those genes were discovered
decades ago before the Human Genome
Project and before we could scan all
three billion base pairs at the same
time
and when we do this for patients having
heart attack we find that the top hot
spot for having a heart attack is
located on chromosome 9 shown here with
these blue dots
and what shocked the world when this
paper was first published was that this
genetic Locus has nothing to do with
smoking or cholesterol or diabetes
but actually seems to control a
well-known cancer Gene that's mutated in
patients with melanoma brain cancer lung
cancer Etc and so for decades we've been
focusing on the traditional cardiac risk
factors
but the genetics now tell us that the
most important factor may actually have
to do with a well-known cancer Gene
instead
well that's an interesting observation
but we know that if you look under the
microscope at these two diseases they
couldn't be more different
when I was in medical school I was
taught that cancer is really just about
cells dividing too quickly and you can
imagine this lung tumor growing over
time and taking over the lung
and that this has nothing to do with
what happens in heart disease which is a
problem that I was taught was due to the
buildup of cholesterol that can
ultimately lead to the blockage of an
artery and the heart attack or a stroke
and to be sure both of these biological
processes are critically important but I
would point out that the modern day
textbook of these diseases is getting
harder and harder to tell apart we now
know that both of these conditions are
dominated by the influx of inflammatory
cells and immune cells and abnormal
blood vessels and even stem cells and so
maybe the textbooks that I used are out
of date
well at this point you might say these
are interesting observations but is
there any clinical data which would
suggest that patients with one disease
are actually at higher risk of the other
turns out that investigators both in
Asia and Europe have now started to test
this hypothesis and just last year a
very important article was published out
of Germany where they looked at more
than a hundred thousand individuals with
congestive heart failure and they found
that these people were at much higher
risk of developing cancer
this is really interesting and suggests
to me that indeed having one disease may
put you at risk of of the other
but this also raises a very important
scientific principle that Association is
not the same as causation and if you
wanted to test that hypothesis you would
have to do an experiment where you took
a healthy individual and then
intentionally gave them a heart attack
you'd have to let some time go by to see
what changes occur throughout the body
and then you could determine if their
rate of cancer was higher or vice versa
if their rate of heart disease was
higher
now obviously we can't do this type of
an experiment in human beings this would
be unethical
but this type of an experiment is done
in Research Laboratories every day
around the world in Mouse models of
human disease
just last year two very important
studies were published where
investigators took healthy mice and then
implanted small tumors underneath their
skin
they looked at the rate at which these
cancers would grow over time
and what they found in both studies was
that the mice who had heart disease had
much higher rates of cancer
and what was fascinating to me was that
they were able to confirm these findings
across a wide range of tumors suggesting
to me that really the presence of heart
disease is sufficient to accelerate
cancer growth
so having heard all this the natural
question is whether we can do anything
about this
so outside of my work at Stanford one of
my volunteer roles is with the American
Heart Association and one of our Public
Health initiatives is called life simple
seven
we try to get patients with a history of
heart disease to control these very
simple and straightforward risk factors
like exercise cholesterol and diet
the idea here is that if you can control
these you should be able to lower your
risk of having additional cardiovascular
events this is now pretty widely
accepted
but what's fascinating to me is that a
group of investigators have now looked
at the association with these risk
factors and cancer
and in a study with more than 10 000
individuals who were followed for almost
two decades they found the people who
had optimal control of all their risk
factors
had a pretty low rate of developing
cancer
but for each risk factor which fell out
of control the risk of malignancy went
up
and you can see that the group who had
poor control of all seven risk factors
had by far the highest rates of cancer
with nearly a doubling of the risk
so this suggests to me that in fact if
we want to control cancer we might start
by controlling our cardiac risk profile
so this is fine and we continue to
encourage our patients to do this
but the reality is that even if I had a
magic wand and could somehow optimally
control everybody's risk factors we know
that we would still be dealing with both
number one and number two causes of
death worldwide
this tells us that we need to find new
therapies that could treat or even
prevent these conditions in the first
place
now our laboratory chooses to do this
with an unbiased genetics approach
we take biopsies from patients with or
without a wide variety of tumors or with
and without cardiovascular disease and
instead of looking at one gene at a time
we scan the whole genome and look at the
expression of all 20 000 genes
you can plot these on a plot like this
where each gray dot represents its own
Gene
and when you acquire enough samples you
can begin to identify patterns of those
genes which are bad for cancer versus
those that protect against it
and do the same type of an experiment to
find those things that will accelerate
or prevent against cardiovascular
disease
now I think the clever part of this
approach is to integrate these and to
run these analyzes simultaneously
when you do this we can begin to look at
factors in the red quadrant these are
genes that we suspect should be bad for
both heart disease and cancer and must
be avoided at all costs
or even better perhaps we can find
factors in the blue quadrant that should
be able to protect against both diseases
we hypothesize that those factors in the
blue quadrant could be prioritized to
help us find new medicines to cure these
two leading killers
now our group has run these analyzes on
several thousand individuals this work
is still underway
but so far we've identified a list of
about three dozen Pathways that we do
think should be prioritized
now time will tell if these work if all
of them work if some if any of them work
we just don't know
but I do want to show you a couple of
examples that would suggest that we're
on the right path
in the red quadrant one of the factors
we found relates to inflammation
and we often think of inflammation as
being bad but in reality this is a
process that our body evolved to help us
recover from injury or an amount of
fever to fight off an infection
but of course there are always times
where our body has too much of something
in this case there's a rare genetic
syndrome where children can be born with
overactive inflammation and they can
have recurrent episodes of high fevers
and rashes and other neurocognitive and
developmental delays
now in a Triumph of science
investigators have pinpointed the exact
molecule responsible for this and they
developed a drug that can block it
these children who have these rashes
that I mentioned before can have a
relatively remarkable Improvement on
these drugs and almost get back to a
normal quality of life
but relevant to today's talk it turns
out that there are a group of
cardiologists who for decades have
hypothesized that these same
inflammatory factors may also be driving
heart disease
they were able to convince the company
that makes this drug to do a trial to
look at the effect of this medicine in
patients who had had a heart attack or a
stroke in the past
and really it was no surprise to many of
us when the results of this trial were
published and they showed that in fact
compared to a placebo that this medicine
could prevent recurrent cardiovascular
events
but our algorithms predict that this
drug should not only helped prevent
heart disease but also should be able to
prevent cancer
and so this particular article gained a
lot of attention because when they
unblinded their results the
investigators were shocked to find that
not only were the patients having fewer
heart attacks but they were having a
much lower rate of developing lung
cancer at a much lower rate of even
dying from cancer
in fact these results were so surprising
and Powerful that I understand the
company that makes this drug is now
pivoting and prioritizing this as a
cancer drug because the effects were so
significant
how about another example from the blue
quadrant this time
well here we come to one of my favorite
cells in the body which is an immune
cell called the macrophage now
macrophage is from the Greek meaning big
eater
and the role of this cell is to patrol
the body like a sentinel and it looks
for invading bacteria when it sees them
it actually will eat them and remove
them from our body before they can
expand and cause an infection
but just like in the last example there
are oncologists who have hypothesized
that these macrophages don't just have
to eat bacteria but they also have to
look for and eat cancer cells and
hopefully get rid of them before they
can grow and metastasize
and so there's been a major initiative
to develop medicines that can increase
the appetite of these cells to help them
go after those tumors
now this story is still in its early
days and it's unclear if this type of an
approach will work
but some of the early studies would
suggest that patients who have
metastatic lymphoma which you can see
spread throughout this person's body on
their CAT scan
that they may have a remarkable response
to these types of drugs and you can
imagine here that the tumors are melting
away as they're being eaten
by these cells due to their increased
appetite
but once again what we found is that our
algorithms predict that yes this drug
should work for cancer but we think it
might also work for heart disease
and so we've now gone back and
retrospectively analyzed the same CAT
scans from the same cancer patients
but this time instead of looking at the
signal from their tumors
we can look at the signal in their blood
vessels and here I'm pointing with the
arrow to the Carotid artery this is the
artery that brings the blood to the
brain this is where cardiovascular
disease will build up in patients before
they have a stroke and what we found is
that while their cancer was melting away
it looks like their cardiovascular
disease was melting away too
and so once again
these algorithms are predicting that we
may be able to identify therapies that
could be dual purposed to attack both
conditions at the same time
we don't yet know
if any of these other Pathways will have
the same type of success
but what we do know for sure is a lesson
that Galileo taught us almost four
centuries ago
and that there is no such thing as
settled science
we must challenge Dogma we must break
down traditional silos because if we do
we may no longer be powerless against
these leading Killers but may in fact
find ways to treat the world's two
leading killers
thank you
[Applause]